why do I write I write for several
reasons probably for most of which is
it's the only thing I can do to be
honest I say that because I have friends
who I believe are cursed by being
multi-talented and I do feel like that
is a curse or if you're not cursed by
being multi-talented I know people who
are cursed by having many different
interests so their attention is kind of
fragmented across many fields and I
think it's difficult when you're like
that unless you're truly a Renaissance
person and you can kind of handle all of
it at once I think it's hard to sort of
find your way and you know I just never
was interested in anything else I was
never particularly good at anything else
there was there's never been anything
else that I wanted or craved or loved as
much as this work so in that one way I
would say that my life has been
phenomenally simple I've managed to
complicate my life and all sorts of
other ways but but just this was a kind
of I don't know I think in everybody's
life there's one thing that you get
handed as a simple gift and and for me
it was this this whole idea of writing
I follow my curiosity I suppose that's
where most people's creative processes
begin unless they're sort of more
analytical and intellectual about it and
they actually set out to conquer or
understand something which isn't
necessarily how I work I always feel
like it's a tap on the shoulder that
begins it you know and it's it's not
necessarily a passionate response at the
beginning it's curiosity is the best
word for it because you feel this little
tap and then it just pulls your
attention for a minute and you just
think wow that's funny why did I get
that response why am i interested in
lobster fishermen you know why do i what
is that tweak something in me and then
you sort of sniff it out and and for me
I'm not a particularly imaginative
person I have a sister Katherine Murdoch
who's also a writer and she's really a
fabulous Tevan when we were growing up
she was kind of like Scheherazade you
know she can just invent things and make
up worlds and I've never been that kind
of person my interest is much more about
reflecting on the world as it is and
even when I was writing fiction I felt
like I had to go to the places that I
was writing about and roll around in
them for a while and and you know just
really commune with the people there and
like taste the soil you know and learn
about it and so my creative process is
really it's really involving you know
it's really about that kind of all over
sentient sensory experience and and I
can't begin to write something until I
feel like I've become a bit of an expert
on it so the writing comes last and and
it's all this build-up all this research
all this thinking all this contemplation
all this experimentation and then once
I've got this collective of ideas and
information and notes I can sit down and
at that point it starts to feel like I'm
an archaeologist and that underneath all
of those notes there's an ancient city
and I just have to kind of dust it and
find it and piece it together and put
the pieces of pottery and shards and
kind of recreate it in some strange and
kind of indescribable way